[Musique]
je suis certain que vous avez remarqué
notre acteur effectivement je suis
agriculteur mais agriculteurs d'un genre
un peu particulier puisque je suis
agriculteur urbain mais agriculteurs
tout de même alors ce que je voudrais
vraiment vous dire aujourd'hui c'est que
les nouvelles formes d'agriculture
urbaine que je vais vous présenter
doivent et peuvent nourrir
aujourd'hui les gens des villes et que
cette nouvelle manière de produire des
de manger va transformer notre vision
sur l'alimentation sur la ville et
peut-être même sur le vivant alors
pourquoi est-ce que l'agriculture
urbaine doit intervenir aujourd'hui
et bien parce que nos systèmes
alimentaires sont assez déséquilibré
économiquement et souvent dangereux je
sais pas si vous êtes comme moi mais
j'ai beaucoup de mal à me faire à l'idée
que les fruits les légumes que j'achète
dans un supermarché puisse contenir
jusqu'à 17 pesticides différents dont
certains interdits à l'usagé à la vente
en europe comme l'a montré une étude
récente
je sais pas si vous êtes comme moi mais
j'ai beaucoup de mal à me faire à l'idée
que l'agriculture telle qu'elle est
pratiquée aujourd'hui c'est à dire
l'agriculture intensive qui représente
85% de l'agriculture aujourd'hui soit un
énorme contributeurs aux émissions de
gaz à effet de serre notamment au
travers des engrais chimiques qui sont
incorporés dans les sols j'ai aussi
beaucoup de mal à me faire à l'idée que
chacun des aliments que l'on consomme
parcourt en moyenne 2000 km et par
conséquence j'ai beaucoup de mal à me
faire aussi à l'idée que les fruits et
les légumes que je mange soit de qualité
médiocre
tout simplement parce qu'ils ont
précisément été choisi dans des variétés
qui permettent de résister à ce
transport au frigo et qui en plus
son qi vert et enfin j'ai beaucoup de
mal à me faire à l'idée que plus de 80 %
du prix de vente hors taxe aillent à des
intermédiaires des grossistes des
transporteurs des distributeurs et pas
aux producteurs en amont alors face à
cela que peut l agriculture urbaine et
bien il existe de nouvelles formes
extrêmement productive et en particulier
celle ci qui est constitué de colonne de
culture ce sont des colonnes qui sont
entièrement vide entièrement creuse à
pater ya pas de substrats met dedans
circule un mélange de nutriments bio
dissous dans de l'eau c'est extrêmement
productif puisque au sol vous aller
cultiver en moyenne sur 1 mètre carré 9
salade
là vous allez en avoir est âgée sur deux
mètres de haut près d'une cinquantaine
ça permet aussi bien évidemment de
produire avec des variétés qui sont
choisis pour leur goût et que l'on va
cueillir à maturité et ça permet aussi
de cultiver en nutriments bio sans
pesticides sans fongicides et surtout
c'est pas la moindre des choses
ça permet de cultiver en économisant les
ressources et des colonnes de culture
comme celle ci utilise mobilise moins de
10 % de l'eau que vous utiliseriez dans
l'agriculture classique pour produire la
même chose alors on le voit l'idée de
base est bien c'est de produire en eau
sur des toits plein sur des surfaces
inoccupées pour consommer en bas ou
vambre en bas l'idée c'est aussi d'être
évidemment performants économiquement
c'est le cas et compétitif avec les
systèmes d'achat notamment de la grande
distribution et l'idée c'est bien
évidemment aussi d'être parfaitement
intégrés socialement en faisant
travailler des ressources qui
proviennent de la ville si possible des
bâtiments qui sont en dessous
et donc d'offrir aussi un certain nombre
d'emplois aux habitants de la ville
alors on le voit cette manière de
travailler apporte des choses très
différentes et il est plus besoin
forcément des pros fin fond de la creuse
pour faire mieux que le bio je voudrais
que vous preniez un instant pour
imaginer le goût de ses tomates ce
basilique la aux produits avec des
nutriments bio de variétés choisies pour
leur goût cueillis à maturité et récolté
sur le toit de votre habitation de votre
bureau ou de votre supermarché alors
vouloir produire de manière vertueuse
mais intensive comme ça en ville va
changer notre vision de l'alimentation
et des systèmes alimentaires bien
évidemment la première chose que ça va
faire évoluer
eh bien ça va nous obliger à penser ces
systèmes là comme des systèmes fermés
bien évidemment en s'inspirant des
écosystèmes naturels et le rapprochement
qui va s'opérer entre les urbains etc
système là va produire des effets de
rapprochement des idées et on va avoir
de moins en moins de gens complètement
déconnecté de ce qu'ils achètent dans
les supermarchés espérons qu'on aura
aussi de moins en moins des colliers qui
penseront que les haricots booth dans
des boîtes de conserve et les tomates
sur des arbres ketchup
la deuxième chose que ça induit à mon
sens c'est que il nous faut enfin
admettre qu'on ait pleinement entrer
dans ce qu'on appelle l'anthropocène
c'est à dire ses terres où la planète a
été totalement colonisés par l'homme il
va nous falloir admettre que l'on a
effectivement un impact réel sur
l'ensemble des écosystèmes et surtout
sur le climat c'est pas évident pour
tout le monde et ça nous oblige de nous
départir notamment du traditionalisme
qui nous dit il n'ya de salut que dans
des légumes pousser en pleine terre au
fin fond de nos campagnes mais ça nous
oblige aussi à nous départir soit du des
niçois du nihilisme
alors je sais vous avez parfaitement le
droit comme donald trump de me dire non
non le changement climatique c'est un
complot des chinois pour nuire aux
économies occidentales
vous avez le droit mais vous le
comprenez c'est pas mon approche et on
va être dans une approche qui va nous
obliger à regarder de très près qu'elles
sont l'ensemble des ressources qui vont
être consommée et on va les optimiser au
maximum
donc on change de paradigme on n'est
plus dans une logique on va chercher à
tirer le maximum de ressources
naturelles réputé être indéfiniment
disponibles comme par exemple des nappes
phréatiques
la deuxième chose que ça va changer à
mon sens c'est notre vision de la ville
et je pense qu'on va voir la ville de
plus en plus un peu comme une image
fractale
c'est à dire ces images dans lesquelles
quelle que soit l'échelle à laquelle
vous le regardez vous avez le même motif
qu'est ce que ça veut dire tout
simplement que la ville est en nous elle
nous influencent elles ne modifient et
inversement
nos comportements notre manière de vivre
influence la ville si vous prenez par
exemple quelqu'un qui ne mangent que de
la viande
il est évident que ça va modifier
l'écosystème de vente autour d'elle et
en amont encore l'éco système de
production des ressources alimentaires
qu'elles utilisent al'inverse bien
évidemment les produits que nous
mangeons modifie notre santé modifie nos
comportements modifie nos modes de vie
et à notre tour nous influençons la
ville
la deuxième chose à mon sens que ça va
modifier concernant la ville c'est que
ça va nous obliger à la décloisonner et
en particulier à laisser tomber cette
vieille notion qui a fait tant de mal à
nos villes qui est la notion du zonage
le zonage qu'est ce que c'est eh bien ça
nous dit que ici on doit travailler ici
on doit vivre ici on doit produire et
ici on doit se divertir il est évident
que le fait d'amener des fermes urbaines
dans la ville
cass ces barrières et induit des
relations différentes entre les
différentes parties de la ville
enfin je pense que ça va modifier notre
vision du vivant tout simplement parce
que nous allons percevoir la nature
d'une manière différente si je fais un
tout petit retour en arrière à l'époque
des grecs
nous avions des gens absolument fasciné
par le renouvellement perpétuel de la
nature et cette fascination il appelait
ça la fusil a été suivi par l'époque du
moyen-âge où l'homme a dû conquérir des
territoires et pour installer
l'agriculture défricher conquérir des
territoires sur la forêt tout
naturellement cette idée a débouché à
l'époque des lumières sur une autre qui
est que la nature doit devenir esclave
de l'homme et cette nature esclaves de
l'homme on en a trouvé le prolongement
dans l'époque moderne avec l'aide des
scientifiques des agriculteurs et de
fait la nature est véritablement devenu
notre esclaves ce qu'apporte
l'agriculture urbaine
c'est tout simplement l'idée que l'on va
en quelque sorte
naturalisé notre économie est
artificialisé un petit peu le vivant
mais sans l'instrumentaliser c'est un
vivant dont on va chercher à tirer le
meilleur qui va nous rendre des services
et auquel on va rendre des services
et puis la deuxième idée c'est que ces
structures végétales que l'on va
construire vont nous servir à organiser
la résilience à la fois au plan
économique
parce que vous construisez ainsi des
boucles économiques locales qui sont
beaucoup plus résistante aux crises
économiques mais aussi la résilience
face aux changements climatiques en
végétalisant les villes mais aussi en
luttant contre les phénomènes d'îlots de
chaleur
alors voilà ma vision c'est celle d'une
ville où tous les toits plats toutes les
surfaces en déshérence serait utilisé
pour nourrir les urbains avec des
produits de grande qualité
parce que les urbains aujourd'hui
évidemment constituent l'essentiel de
l'humanité et ça veut dire qu'il faut
aller produire de manière hyper local
est partout et je pense en particulier
aux zones dans lesquelles le stress
hydrique se fait le plus sentir
alors voilà vous pensiez peut-être pas
que cultiver des salades nous emmènerait
aussi loin mais l'alimentation ça jamais
été une chose tout à fait neutre
je voudrais vous dire que dans la vie il
ya des accidents
j'en sais quelque chose mais qu'on soit
un simple individu comme moi ou via une
société tout entière
par exemple confronté à l'accident du
changement climatique nous devons être
aujourd'hui le changement que nous
voulons voir à l'oeuvre
comme le disait gandhi et j'ajouterais
personnellement que c'est la voie pour
retrouver notre sentiment d'utilité et
c'est ce que j'essaye de faire avec
l'agriculture urbaine
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]